مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في مجزره من قناه
الجزيره نقلت شبكه ار ان دي الالمانيه عن
متحدث باسم شركه راين ميتال الدفاعيه
الالمانيه ان الشركه قد تسلم 139 دبابه
ليبارد القتاليه الى اوكرانيا اذا لزم
الامر وذلك في حال موافقه الحكومه
الالمانيه
قال مسؤول السياسات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان دول الاتحاد الاوروبي توصلت
خلال اجتماعي وزراء الخارجيه الى اتفاقا
سياسيا على تقديم حزمه السابعه من
المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا
بدورها الخارجيه البلجيه تجميده اصول
روسيه ضخمه واضافته مقابله مع الجزيره ان
استخدام هذه الاصول في اعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا يحتاج الى اطار قانونيا وهو ما
لا يتوفر حتى الان
اعلنت الرئاسه السويديات الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان وزاره الخارجيه الاتحاد اقروا حزمه
جديده من العقوبات على ايران واضافت ان
العقوبات تستهدف من يقودون القمع ضد
المتظاهرين السلميين على حد تعبيرها وقال
بيانونيه الاتحاد الاوروبي ان العقوبات
الجديده ضد الافراد والكيارات الايرانيه
تشمله تجميدا الاصول وحذر السفر الى دول
الاتحاد وحظر اتاحه الاموال لمن هم مدرجنا
في القائمه
من جهته قال مفاوضوا السياسات الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي انه لا يمكن تصنيف الحرس
الثوري منظمه الارهابيه من دون حكم قضائي
من جهتها اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
عقوبات الشملت المؤسسات التعاونيه للحرس
الثوري الايراني وخمسه اعضاء من مجلس
ادارتها ونائب وزير الاستخبارات والامن
واربعه من كبار قاده الحرس الثوري في
ايران
في المقابل حضاره وزير الخارجيه الايراني
الدول الاوروبيه من اتخاذ خطوات يمكن ان
تكون لها تداعيات جسيمه وقال انه في حاله
اتخاذ قرارا ضد مؤسسه السياديه مثل الحرس
الثوري ستشهد ردا قويا ومؤثرا من جانبه
طهران
قرر المحقق العدل في قضيه انفجار بيروت
القاضي طارق البيطار
تحقيقاته في ملف الانفجار كما قرر اخلاء
سبيل خمسه موقفين والدعائها على ثمانيه
اشخاص بينهم مسؤولين امنيان رفيعان مستوى
نظمه اعضاء من حزب اللي كنت في الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي وهو منظمات يمنيه متطرفه
تجمع الخائن الاحمر البدوي شرقيه القدس
المحتله بهدف دفعه محكمه العدل العليا
الاسرائيليه لاتخاذ قرار نهائيا لهدم
التجمع والضغط على الحكومه الاسرائيليه من
اجل تنفيذه وفقا لمنظم التجمع
مشاهديتها